Банки, стратегічні об’єкти інфраструктури, міністерства та приватні компанії: від 15 до 30 тисяч
комп'ютерів в Україні, за попередньою оцінкою, постраждали від атаки вірусу Petya 27 червня.
Убезпечити державні органи мала би так звана "кіберпарасолька", тобто захищений доступ до інтернету.
Чому ж вона не спрацювала? Роман Боярчук  - головний відповідальний за кіберзахист.
Він каже, далеко не усі українські держустанови підключені до "парасольки".
На сьогоднішній день в Україні тільки триває процес формування переліку об’єктів критичної інфраструктури
і їх інформаційно-телекомунікаційних систем.
І лише після того, як цей процес буде завершений, ці об’єкти будуть підлягати захисту під цією парасолькою
Адміністрація Президента та ще 13 держорганів – перебувають під захистом "кіберпарасольки".
Решта – поки ні, нарікає Боярчук. Одразу після атаки РНБО рекомендувала мати захищений доступ до інтернету всім держустановам та банкам.
Однак, схоже, не всі сприймають такі рекомендації серйозно. Вихід із ситуації
експерти бачать у посиленні відповідальності посадовців за незахищеність від кібератак.
Накласти більші відповідальності, а деякі кримінальну відповідальність на посадових осіб,
які відповідають за кібер-безпеку держави, щоб люди розуміли,  якщо вони не захищають
кіберпростір нашої держави, кіберпростір державного підприємства, де знаходяться якісь,
наприклад, дані, від яких критична інфраструктура держави, вони повинні відсидіти у подальшому у в’язниці.
Необхідні для цього закони мала би ухвалити Верховна рада. Проте у травні депутати
провалили голосування за законопроект про кібербезпеку. І відправили його на повторне друге читання.
Тож поки цей документ припадає пилом у парламенті, Україна залишається незахищеною в разі нових атак.
Цього тижня Київ відвідує генсек НАТО Єнс Столтенберг. Напередодні він повідомив, що НАТО
надає Україні обладнання, яке допоможе встановлювати організаторів кібератак. Крім того,
Альянс допомагає українцям у цій сфері навчаннями, технологіями та фінансово. Адже НАТО
розцінює кіберпростір як сферу партнерської військової відповідальності.